le procureur de la république est en
sort qu'a dit ce matin au lendemain de
cette manifestation de cet hommage rendu
hier soir à ducos à jessica gabriel
femme de 42 ans assassinée il y a tout
juste non bonjour renaud gaudeul bonjour
il ya le temps de l'émotion celui de la
justice aussi ceux de l'éducation de la
répression mais on a quand même surtout
la pression renaud gaudeul que ce
phénomène de la violence faite aux
femmes ne recule pas dans notre île
il n'y a pourtant pas de fatalisme dire
qu'il ne recule pas je n'en sais rien en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
les efforts que nous entreprenons
aujourd'hui n'auront d'effet que dans
plusieurs années il faut il faut pas se
voiler la face et pour autant il ne faut
pas ne pas réaliser dès à présent ses
efforts qui sont absolument impératif si
on veut pouvoir agir sur le long terme
sur ce type de sur ce type de faits est
ce qu'il y aura de nouveaux dispositifs
que durant cette année 2010 9 alors nous
avons déjà au cours des deux dernières
années nous sommes dotés déjà d'un
nombre de dispositifs qui sont quand
même je crois très important et la
convention notamment pour éloigner le
conjoint violent
sas et voilà c'est une des dernières
initiatives effectivement c'est cette
convention qui permet maintenant de
mettre en place de manière très concrète
l'éviction du conjoint violent c'est à
dire de faire en sorte que lorsqu'il ya
des violences qui sont commises au sein
d'un couple lorsqu'il convient qu'il y
en ait un qui quitte le domicile ce ne
soit plus comme c'était beaucoup trop
souvent le cas par le passé
la victime qui était concrètement obligé
de partir et parfois avec ses enfants
cela n'était pas tolérable et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons mis en
place donc cette convention qui ferme
permet de faire en sorte que ce soit
l'auteur des faits qui quitte le
domicile conjugal et puis le téléphone
d'urgence
absolument c'est le téléphone grave
danger également que nous avons mis en
place à partir de 2017 est qui et qui
est un dispositif qui a une véritable
réalité au cours de l'été dernier il y
avait ainsi neuf téléphones graves
dangers qui était déployé dans
l'ensemble de la martinique et on a
aujourd'hui il y en a il y en a sept
il y a également par exemple sage que
nous avons mis en place qui permettent
aujourd'hui de réprimer les auteurs de
faits qui commettent leur premier geste
et quelle que soit la violence de ce
premier jet c'est à dire que le sujet
fait juste physiquement blanche des
sceaux au ca peut même être un peu hein
vous savez que l'alliance doit être
également une violence psychologique
absolument le seul fait de commettre ces
faits la neo geo est aujourd'hui
réprimer ce qui n'était pas le cas par
le passé au ou alors on se contentait
d'un rappel à la loi mais ça ne
suffisait absolument pas et par
conséquent aujourd'hui le moindre
commencement de petits gestes fait
l'objet d'une réponse pénale et cette
réponse pénale c'est quoi c'est
l'obligation de suivre un stage qui a
quand même qui dure sur sur trois
journées et pour le cours duquel on
explique à la personne pourquoi est-ce
que le geste est interdite et comment
faire pour éviter d'en passer
il est peut-être un peu tôt pour parler
déjà des premiers résultats de cet
observatoire territoriale de cette
vision de ce phénomène de violence faite
aux femmes mais n'empêche que les
associations féministes de lille
c'est à plat ces dernières semaines ces
derniers mois ces dernières années du
mauvais accueil dans les commissariats
de police de gendarmerie
lorsqu'on venait se plaît parce que ça
c'est ça fait partie du passé maintenant
en tout cas c'est une c'est une critique
qui est prise en compte
on ne m'a parole nation pas de vous dire
oui l'accueil est absolument parfait à
chaque fois qu'une victime se présente
et par conséquent là aussi nous avons
pris cela en compte et pas plus tard que
la semaine dernière il ya eu ainsi une
formation qui a été réalisé deux
fonctionnaires de police formation sur
l'accueil des victimes de violences au
sein du couple
et là aussi l'objectif étant de faire en
sorte que cet accueil s'améliore au fil
du temps en fin de semaine dernière nos
beaux de l'île ya eu les audiences
solennelles de rentrée au tribunal de
grande instance il y a été question de
lutte contre la délinquance organisées
sur tout le secteur de la finance et de
l'économie en nous on en avait on a
voulu croire que la martinique pouvait
échapper à ce genre de choses il n'est
rien du tout non dur je sais pas si
quelqu'un voulu y croire en tout cas une
définition déjà cette délinquance
organisée dans les secteurs de la
finance et de l'économie si ça concerne
quoi exactement
en fait c'est une heure c'est un domaine
extrêmement divers exemples de ne pas
pouvoir faire le le
une revue de détail des logis leur pass
pass poupée moi c'est ma peau de fraude
d'entrée de rentrées d'argent suspects
tu sais quoi voilà c'est à peu près tout
tout cela un et tout ce qui est
également tout ce qui est légalement
fraudes fiscales qui existent fraudes en
tous genres qui sont une réalité ici en
martinique pour que ça et ça et c'est
une réalité voilà je ne dirais pas que
c'est nécessairement forcément beaucoup
plus qu'ailleurs mais en tout cas c'est
une réalité qui méritent quand on la
combat combattent et ce d'autant que
parfois les dispositifs qui sont mis en
place par ces individus fraudeurs sont
parfois assez complexe et qu'il n'est
pas toujours évident ainsi de mener ses
enquêtes ils sont des enquêtes à long
terme
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
en avons plusieurs dossiers faut pas non
plus se voiler la face qui n'ont pas
avancé je le dis franchement qu'ils
n'ont pas avancé à la vitesse à laquelle
j'aurais souhaité qu'ils avancent et
notamment en raison de mutations trop
fréquente de magistrats du siège com de
com du parquet c'est-à-dire en
l'occurence deux magistrats instructeurs
et également de magistrat au parquet qui
parfois est bien on a eu ces postes de
lutte contre cette délinquance
économique et financière et qui sont
partis au bout de un an voire deux ans
mais un an deux ans c'est trop court
lorsqu on a en charge des dossiers qui
soit aussi lourd ce avec elin affaires
retentissantes ces dernières années en
martinique c'est la sphère du céreq
belle affaire du ceri gaza pourrait être
par exemple quelque chose qui
rentreraient dans cette délinquance
financière économique très clairement
oui
ce en fait partie et l'exemple que vous
citez fait partie des dossiers sur
lesquels voilà je crois qu'il faut que
l'on que l'on progresse de manière de
plus rapidement c'est pas une a fait
rentrer dans l'histoire de ses
régulières en aucun cas la lutte contre
la violence la délinquance la drogue en
milieu scolaire il s'agit là encore de
quoi de répression ou d'éducation de
prévention il en a été question il ya
encore quelques semaines il ya tout cela
tout cela c'est à dire qu'en
l'occurrence si vous ne faites
fonctionner qu'un seul des moteurs que
vous avez parlé la répression tout seul
ça ne servira pas à grand chose
l'éducation tout seul ne suffit pas
toujours même si ça doit être absolument
prioritaires là là dessus il n'y a pas
de discussion avant tout lorsqu'on en
parle notamment là je vous évoquez bien
le cas de celle de la présence d'armes
où la présence de drogue en milieu
scolaire c'est avant tout une affaire
d'éducation on est parfaitement d'accord
mais parfois également lorsque l'on a
effectivement des infractions qui sont
commises
lorsqu'elles sont parfaitement constaté
et lorsque parfois le simple discours
éducatif ne suffit pas et ça arrive à ce
moment là il est bien normal que ces
zones éducative ne soient pas des zones
de non droit en aucun cas et alors il
nous appartient d'agir
mais comment ça peut se passer vous
imaginez un gendarme un policier qui
rentre dans un établissement scolaire à
quel point ça peut être au bâtiment pour
nos chers jeunes non a justement c'est
tout l'objet de cette convention qui a
été signée en plein accord avec tous les
partenaires et en l'occurrence
précisément c'est de mettre en place un
dispositif qui ne permettent pas
effectivement de créer le moindre
traumatisme et qui permettent en
l'occurrence d'effectuer ces contrôles
là mais de manière tout à fait sereine
et en faisant en sorte que le personnel
éducatif soit totalement associés à ces
différents contrôles qui encore une fois
sont nécessaires nous sont demandées par
le personnel éducatif nous sont
demandées par les élèves eux-mêmes
et puisque le serait également
officiellement par l'art enquêtes sur
des affaires n'ont pas particulièrement
mais c'est pas parce qu'on ne va pas
attendre qu'il y ait une augmentation
pour agir voilà donc en l'occurrence et
bien qu'il y ait augmentation pas il
faut que nous agissions on a parlé d'une
année judiciaire très chargé en
martinique l'année dernière en 2018
illustration par les chiffres par
exemple aux nôtres gaudeul le taux
d'élucidation des affaires et ça donne
quoi en martinique
et bien c'est alors nous n'avons pas
encore les chiffres pour l'ensemble du
territoire national mais ce taux
d'élucidation est l'un des plus élevés
pour ne pas dire le plus élevé au niveau
national en aura l'occasion de
de revenir je pense dans les prochains
jours avec le préfet plus précisément
sur ces différents chiffres de la
délinquance mais ce qui est certain
c'est que nous nous avons assisté en
2018 à une baisse de la délinquance
et paradoxalement en même temps à une
augmentation des affaires qui ont été
élucidés et lorsque vous avez ainsi de
ces de droite qui se qui se croisent et
bien que vous avez une augmentation de
ce taux d'élucidation avec un tout comme
de près de 53% ce qui encore une fois
est un taux très élevé donc là de ce
point de vue là la martinique fait bien
incontestablement la sq il convient
également d'indiquer c'est que à partir
du moment où vous avez ainsi un tel taux
d'élucidation il faut également que les
juridictions se met en état pour pouvoir
faire face à cet afflux est parmi les
données sur des moyens c'est la question
des moyens est ce que des voix de la
justice
globalement sont correctes en martinique
ce qui a suffisamment de monde au moyen
pour ceux qui sont sur le terrain pour
ceux qui mènent des enquêtes ceux qui
traitent les dossiers ceux qui jugent et
c'est qui qui enferme les prisonniers
oui alors en tout cas ce qui est très
clair c'est que il y a eu une
augmentation plus que substantielle des
moyens dans tous les secteurs au cours
des des récentes années c'est vrai pour
le service de police et gendarmerie je
pense par exemple pas seulement par
exemple à l'augmentation de 25% quand
même
en l'espace de deux ans des effectifs de
la police judiciaire je pense à
l'ouverture d'une antenne de l'eau
certis à cayenne ce qui nous nous
intéresse en matière de lutte contre la
grande délinquance en matière de trafic
de produits stupéfiants notamment
je pense également à l'ouverture en
septembre 2018 c'est quand même tout
récent d'un nouveau service qui le
service national des douanes judiciaires
qui est également un service attendu au
niveau 2 au niveau des moyens au niveau
du tribunal là aussi je ne peux pas vous
dire que les moyens sont nécessairement
suffisant bien sûr qu'on soit toujours
en avoir plus et on continue à ont
souhaité de souhaité en avoir plus mais
en revanche qu'il faut également
reconnaître c'est qu'au cours des
récentes années il ya eu une
augmentation indéniable des effectifs
et c'est là qu'on va aborder avec le
sourire cette fameuse notion de
sentiment de sécurité
oui alors je effectivement alors sa
raison il y avait ce sentiment
d'insécurité qui n'est pas
nécessairement toujours en corrélation
couple habitait le froid ressenti voilà
voilà c'est exactement cela
à dire vrai je n'ai pas d'indicateurs
récents sur ce fameux sentiment
d'insécurité qui quelque chose qui se
calculent j'ai pu j'ai pas de données
extrêmement récente en tout cas ce qui
est ce qui est clair quand même moi
quand je discute avec différents
interlocuteurs note quand même qu'il y a
qu on est en conflit encore un travail
colossal à réaliser mais me semble-t-il
qu on est plutôt sur une bonne voie je
pense notamment
on a parlé encore tout récemment de ses
vols à main armée qui sont un véritable
fléau va aussi ici en martinique
là aussi je crois que on a quand même
bien progressé en 2018 dans
l'élucidation de ses affaires et
lorsqu'on lui lorsque l'on est lucide
plus d'affaires de cette nature on évite
la commission de nouvelles infractions
dernière question en 20 secondes renaud
gaudeul la coopération régionale ça
avance oui ça avance ça a été mon point
de vue là aussi un peu long je pense
notamment à cette convention avec sainte
lucie face à ces conventions parce qu'il
y en a deux il y en a une qui porte sur
l'extradition et l'autre qui porte sur
la coopération judiciaire en matière en
matière pénale
ça a été long parce que ce sont des
accords qui ont été signés il ya plus de
deux ans et il fallait qu'il entre en
application si requis soit ratifiée par
le parlement
et cela vient tout juste d'être réalisé
merci renaud gaudeul pour que vers de la
république merci d'avoir été ce matin
dans son caddie bonne journée
[Musique]